Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde :
"l'Europe qui veut en finir
avec Poutine."
Depuis le déclenchement
de l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
en février 2022,
l'Union Européenne est montée
en gamme
dans son soutien à Kiev,
et symétriquement
dans son opposition à la Russie.
En même temps, on a observé
la constitution
d'une Europe anti-Poutine,
par la solidarité,
une proximité charnelle
et une histoire qui remonte à loin
dans les territoires
d'Europe centrale
et orientale.
Autour de Varsovie et Vilnius,
mais sans la Biélorussie,
toujours inféodée à Moscou,
c'est le passé culturel,
politique et identitaire
d'une région célébrée
par le grand poète Adam Mickiewicz
dans son chef-d'oeuvre
"Pan Tadeusz".
De son côté,
le grand écrivain tchèque
Milan Kundera
a montré,
dans "Un Occident kidnappé",
la voie de liberté
et d'indépendance engagée
par les nations centre-européennes,
qui subirent
le joug du Troisième Reich nazi
et de l'URSS stalinienne.
Sans conteste, du fait
et en conséquence de ce conflit
meurtrier,
et de plus en plus dévastateur,
se profilent à la fois
un nouvel élargissement
de l'Union Européenne
et une sécurité européenne
renforcée,
en partenariat avec l'OTAN,
intégrant, à moyen terme,
l'Ukraine
et d'autres pays de la région.
Bien sûr, personne ne souhaite,
au sein de l'Europe,
d'une nouvelle guerre froide,
mais un clivage
est en train de s'établir
entre des pays
à vocation libérale et démocratique
et des pays autoritaires,
nationalistes, expansionnistes,
toujours à la recherche
d'une expansion territoriale.
Pour en parler, je vous présente
mes invités.
Jan Emeryk Rosciszewski,
vous êtes ambassadeur
de Pologne en France.
Michal Fleischmann,
vous êtes ambassadeur
de la République tchèque en France.
Nerijus Aleksiejunas, vous êtes
ambassadeur de Lituanie en France.
Et Bruno Tertrais, politologue,
directeur adjoint
de la Fondation
pour la recherche stratégique.
Vous venez de voir la citation
d'Adam Mickiewicz :
"Créer un monde nouveau
sur les ruines de l'ancien."
L'Europe centrale et orientale
aura connu
des occupations militaires,
notamment soviétiques et allemandes,
des déplacements de population,
des exterminations,
des famines imposées,
des mouvements nationalistes
revanchards.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que la guerre actuelle en Ukraine
s'inscrit dans cette continuité
impériale et expansionniste
de la Russie ?
M. l'ambassadeur de Pologne.
-D'abord, j'aimerais
vous remercier beaucoup
d'être venu
avec cette citation
de notre grand poète,
notamment de notre ancien
Commonwealth polono-lituanien,
Adam Mickiewicz,
qui écrivait justement :
"la Lituanie, ma patrie",
en étant en même temps lituanien
et polonais.
C'est un personnage
qui est absolument remarquable
pour revenir
à cette époque, justement,
de la Pologne et de la Lituanie,
créant un pays commun,
il y a presque 300 ans.
Je pense que bon, la réponse
à votre question,
si on peut dire très vite,
c'est oui.
Il faut d'abord gagner la guerre,
pour l'Ukraine.
Il faut que l'Ukraine gagne
la guerre.
Il faut que la Russie se retire
des territoires ukrainiens,
et il faut qu'on rétablisse la paix,
dont on a absolument besoin,
mais pas sous
n'importe quelles conditions,
bien évidemment.
La Pologne, depuis le début,
pas uniquement
depuis février 2022,
mais depuis Maïdan, et même avant,
est un pays
qui a toujours soutenu l'Ukraine.
On essayait de convaincre
nos alliés
que l'Ukraine appartenait,
historiquement parlant,
à cette zone de l'Europe qui doit
avoir la liberté,
et doit appartenir
à cette zone
de la liberté européenne.
Et je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
l'Ukraine a bien prouvé
que la situation est telle
que l'Ukraine
a besoin de devenir
un des membres
de la communauté européenne
et de l'OTAN à l'avenir.
La Pologne
a fait absolument tout
pour soutenir l'Ukraine.
-On va revenir,
si vous voulez,
sur vos propos,
mais sur cette question précise,
monsieur Aleksiejunas,
est-ce que vous pensez
que la Russie d'aujourd'hui,
c'est la même
que la Russie tsariste ?
C'est la même
que la Russie bolchevique ?
C'est une continuité,
finalement,
de cet impérialisme ?
-Je pense que notre histoire
donne cette réponse très claire,
parce que pour nous,
c'est une continuation
de cette agressivité,
de cet impérialisme,
qui a existé
à l'époque
du Grand-duché de Lituanie
et de la république
des Deux Nations.
C'était toujours cette pression,
du côté russe,
sur notre territoire,
sur notre pays.
Bien sûr, il y a eu la période
de l'Empire russe,
quand la Lituanie
a été occupée
par la Russie.
Il y a eu aussi
deux grandes insurrections
pendant cette époque,
celles de la Lituanie
de la Pologne.
Il y avait toujours
cette tendance
à ce que notre pays aille
en direction
de l'Europe,
pour vraiment créer l'Europe
ensemble,
pour créer une Europe
plus forte.
Et puis, il y a eu
la période de l'URSS.
On parle beaucoup
des crimes de Poutine,
mais avant,
il y avait les crimes de Staline,
les crimes
de Gorbachev.
Le 13 janvier 1991,
à Vilnius,
14 Lituaniens
ont été tués.
C'est une séquence qui a déjà existé
dans notre histoire.
Maintenant,
ce qu'il se passe en Ukraine,
c'est une continuation
de cette agressivité.
Peut-être que nous avons fait
quelques erreurs
après la chute
de l'Union Soviétique.
C'était peut-être
une erreur
de ne pas avoir eu
un débat très franc
sur cette période
de l'URSS,
sur les crimes
de Staline,
sur ce que ça veut dire
pour nous, pour les autres.
On a essayé d'éviter
ce débat un peu sensible.
-Bruno Tertrais,
pas de rupture
avec Poutine ?
Ca continue ?
-Je dirais que s'il y a eu
une période un peu différente,
avec ses bons côtés
et ses mauvais côtés,
ça a été
la période Eltsine.
C'est une sorte
de parenthèse
que l'on hésiterait
à qualifier d'enchantée.
Ca a été une parenthèse
pendant laquelle de nombreux Russes
ont été très malheureux.
Pour reprendre l'expression
que vous avez utilisée,
je dirais que Poutine
n'est pas l'héritier du bolchevisme.
Lui,
il fait une synthèse
entre le tsarisme
et le stalinisme.
C'est pas tellement
le bolchevisme lui-même.
Je dirais que lui,
il s'inspire, et il le dit...
Staline est réhabilité,
mais Lénine,
en revanche,
qui était l'homme
qui prétendait
reconnaître les nations
constitutives de l'Union Soviétique,
est oublié,
voire brocardé.
On parle même...
Poutine lui-même
a parlé
de la décision funeste
de Lénine de décider
du statut de l'Ukraine, etc.
Je dirais qu'il est
toujours difficile d'essentialiser,
de parler de l'ADN politique
d'un pays.
Force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui,
la Russie
a totalement renoué
avec un comportement
qu'on l'a vu avoir
pendant des siècles,
ce que nous, Français,
avons eu du mal
à reconnaître, tant nous avions
une vision romantique
de la Russie, qui date du moment
où nous étions nous-même
un empire.
Il y a deux catégories :
il y a les empires guéris
et les empires malades,
ou encore malades.
La France, à mon avis,
est un empire guéri.
Ce n'est plus
un pays impérial.
La Russie est encore,
fondamentalement,
un empire
avec un comportement
impérial et colonial.
-Monsieur Fleischmann,
je voudrais qu'on précise ce point
par rapport à ce qui a été dit.
La Russie
de Poutine,
et Poutine lui-même...
On vient d'entendre dire
que c'est plutôt Staline que Lénine.
Autrement dit, c'est toujours
l'expansion territoriale,
mais sans idéologie.
C'est bien ça ?
-C'est exactement ça.
Je me permets de reprendre
les mots de Vaclav Havel,
qui a dit que le problème
de la Russie,
c'est de ne pas savoir
où elle commence et où elle finit.
-C'est le principe des empires.
-C'est le principe des empires
et nous avons
l'expérience historique
de l'impérialisme russe,
qu'il soit tsariste,
qu'il soit communiste
ou poutinien.
Vous avez parlé
du romantisme français.
On a eu un regard
trop romantique
par rapport
à la Russie,
même celle des tsars,
qui à des moments divers,
étaient des tsars
d'origine allemande.
Là, on a eu
des espoirs.
On a eu des espoirs,
avec...
Avec Gorbachev,
on a eu un petit espoir,
mais ce sont
des regards romantiques,
même par rapport
à la littérature,
à l'art russe,
à l'art soviétique.
On a eu des espoirs
de l'européanisme
de la Russie.
C'est des espoirs déçus.
C'est des espoirs faux.
Ce romantisme...
-Monsieur Fleischmann,
je voulais
une précision.
Dans "Vie et destin",
Vassili Grossman dit...
C'est son grand livre.
Il dit que la Russie
n'a jamais connu
la démocratie.
Comment se fait-il
que la Russie
a eu des gouvernements
avec des princes,
des tsars,
des chefs révolutionnaires
qui venaient quelquefois
de l'Occident,
et que la démocratie
n'a jamais pris
dans ce pays-là ?
-Parce que c'est un grand pays,
un énorme pays,
et que, tout simplement,
la population russe
n'est pas habituée
et éduquée dans le sens
de la démocratie.
Elle ne connaît pas cela.
C'est une population vassalisée
depuis des siècles
et des siècles.
Ils se sont habitués
à cela
et ont toujours
le "papouchka",
le tsar,
le père, le grand-père...
Mais vous avez
parfaitement raison,
ça n'a jamais vraiment eu
d'idéologie.
L'idéologie a tout simplement servi
à asservir la population
à l'aide de la Tchéka,
de la police
ou bien de l'Eglise,
l'Eglise orthodoxe.
C'est tout
ce contexte-là.
Il faudrait un jour,
quand même,
commencer à se rendre compte
que la Russie,
ce n'est pas l'euro...
Ce n'est pas
européen,
mais c'est beaucoup plus
l'Eurasie qu'autre chose.
-Monsieur Rosciszewski,
à vous.
-Justement,
pour continuer ce que disait
mon collègue,
monsieur Fleischmann...
Vous avez
tout à fait raison.
Le fondement de l'histoire
de la civilisation russe
est complètement différent
du fondement
de la civilisation européenne,
de tous nos pays.
D'accord ? Donc...
La principauté moscovite...
Parce que c'est ça, en fait,
qui a été le berceau.
C'est pas la Kiev,
en fait.
C'est la principauté moscovite
qui est le berceau de la Russie.
La Fédération russe
actuelle
a été fondée sur une base
totalement différente.
Elle était esclave
des Mongols.
Elle se trouvait
sous la domination
de Gengis Khan.
C'est un pays
qui n'a jamais connu
l'histoire médiévale,
la "Chanson de Roland",
qui n'a jamais connu
la perception
de l'honneur.
C'est une population
qui a été fondée sur des bases
totalement différentes...
-Mais Tchekhov
et Tolstoï ne sont pas
des auteurs totalitaires.
-On parle
de très grands écrivains,
de très grands musiciens,
de très grands poètes,
qui appartiennent
à la culture universelle.
Franchement, j'ose dire
qu'ils n'appartiennent pas
à la culture européenne.
Ils appartiennent
à la culture russe.
La culture russe,
c'est pas la culture européenne,
parce que comme je disais,
la Russie ne connaissait pas
le moyen âge,
la Renaissance,
l'époque baroque
ou même l'époque romaine.
Si vous voulez,
toutes proportions gardées
et avec tout mon respect,
c'est une civilisation
complètement à part.
C'est un cercle culturel
qui n'appartient pas
à la culture occidentale.
Bien sûr, il y avait
des représentants
de la Russie.
Il y a certains écrivains
qui essayaient
d'être européens,
mais ils n'étaient jamais
européens.
Quand vous voyez,
quand vous regardez,
quand vous lisez
les plus grands ouvrages
de la littérature russe,
que j'admire,
ce n'est jamais
de la littérature européenne.
C'est de la littérature,
de la culture universelle.
Peut-être que Michel
est d'accord avec moi...
-Je crois
que monsieur Aleksiejunas
voulait intervenir
là-dessus.
-Peut-être juste
pour continuer ce propos,
pour moi, c'est aussi des valeurs
un peu différentes.
C'est peut-être parfois
une erreur de notre part
de juger, de penser
et d'évaluer
Poutine et son régime par rapport
à nos propres valeurs.
Les valeurs en Russie
sont un peu différentes.
Bien sûr, cette période
de la démocratie a été très courte.
Ca a été
la période d'Eltsine.
Peut-être
il y avait un espoir
de voir
la Russie démocratique,
mais ça n'a pas
bien marché.
-Oui,
monsieur Fleischmann ?
-Tout simplement...
Nos pays...
Tels que nous sommes ici,
nous nous sommes
toujours définis
en nous défendant
de l'occupation,
contre quelqu'un,
que ce soit de l'expansion russe
ou de l'Union Soviétique,
que ce soit
devant les Allemands,
ou que ce soit,
maintenant d'une manière
plus générale,
de la volonté russe
de nous considérer
comme des Slaves soumis.
Nous,
on ne s'est jamais soumis.
On s'est définis
en se battant.
Les Russes
ne sont "vraiment"
jamais battus
pour défendre leur pays...
-Stalingrad,
ça existe.
-A part ces moments-là,
à part ces moments où,
tout d'un coup, il y avait
une certaine communauté d'idées
qui a existé à travers l'Europe.
Aujourd'hui,
il n'y a pas l'idéologie,
et nous sommes
dans une situation
de guerre,
une situation
qui a changé.
Nous ne sommes plus
en guerre ensemble,
mais nous sommes en guerre,
nous sommes attaqués.
Attaqués
en tant que tels,
attaqués dans nos cultures,
dans nos valeurs,
dans nos systèmes politiques.
Nous sommes attaqués
par la Russie.
L'attaque de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine,
c'est une attaque
contre l'ensemble de l'Europe.
-Merci.
Bruno Tertrais, je voudrais
qu'on précise quelque chose.
Je voudrais aussi,
dans cette émission,
rendre hommage
à Milan Kundera.
Milan Kundera
a écrit quelques lignes,
"Un Occident kidnappé".
Ca a été repris
par Emmanuel Macron
au cours
d'une réunion
à Bratislava.
Est-ce qu'à votre avis...
Vous partagez
ce diagnostic
de Kundera ?
C'est-à-dire
que les pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale
ont été sous le joug
à la fois nazi
et stalinien,
mais en se débarrassant
de cette double tutelle,
c'est une culture
qui émerge,
c'est quelque chose
de nouveau
et un souffle nouveau
qui est apporté à l'Europe.
-Globalement, oui.
Juste un mot
pour terminer
sur la nature de la Russie.
J'aime bien résumer
sa nature politique
en disant que c'est un pays
qui marche sur deux jambes,
une jambe asiatique
et une européenne,
sauf que celle-ci,
c'est l'Ukraine.
L'Ukraine a énormément apporté
à la culture russe, dont on a parlé,
aux élites russes,
qui souvent étaient,
pour les meilleures,
d'origine ukrainienne.
Aujourd'hui,
la jambe ukrainienne tombe,
ou plutôt s'échappe.
Elle rentre à la maison,
d'une certaine manière,
comme vos pays,
qui sont rentrés à la maison
en 1991.
C'est ce qu'on a mis du temps
à comprendre en France,
cette idée
selon laquelle...
L'Europe de l'Est,
comme on disait,
c'était l'Europe
"de la deuxième classe".
On était la première classe,
et eux, la deuxième.
Des pays qui sortaient
du communisme...
Les costumes étaient gris,
les gens pauvres...
-Monsieur Macron
a rayé ça.
-Pardon ?
-Ce propos a été effacé
par monsieur Macron
pendant son discours
à Bratislava.
"Il n'y a pas deux Europe."
-C'est exactement cela,
et je pense que les Français
ont mis du temps
à se rendre compte
que vos pays étaient
aussi européens que nous,
et que cette idée
de deux Europe,
même si elle a été effacée
officiellement en 1991,
on a eu
beaucoup plus de mal,
de notre côté,
à l'effacer dans la tête.
Votre histoire
et votre position géographique
sont deux choses distinctes.
Le fait d'avoir connu,
pour vous tous,
d'abord le communisme,
le nazisme...
En plus,
avec les allers-retours !
En Ukraine,
ça a été des allers-retours.
Ca a été
la triple peine,
pas que la double peine.
Je crois
que le discours
dont vous parlez...
C'est pas la première fois
qu'Emmanuel Macron célèbre l'unité,
mais il est assez rare
de voir un président français
aller aussi loin
dans la volonté
de reconnaître officiellement
et de dire : "Nous ne sommes pas
"deux Europe.
"Il ne faut pas qu'il y ait,
à l'avenir,
"une Europe très anti-Poutine
qui ne pense qu'à l'Est
"et une Europe
"plus latine et méditerranéenne
qui pense différemment..."
C'est pas seulement
un discours de repentance,
même si c'est un peu
un discours de repentance.
Il y a du repentir
vis-à-vis des propos
prononcés
par un prédécesseur...
-Jacques Chirac ?
-Pour ne pas le nommer.
-Au moment de la guerre d'Irak.
-Oui, voilà.
-Il avait demandé
à ces pays
d'une manière triviale
de la boucler.
-On va revenir une minute
sur ce sujet.
Pourquoi Chirac le dit
à ce moment-là ?
Il est persuadé que l'Amérique
est en train de mettre la main
sur l'Europe centrale.
Il ne comprend pas
que si ces pays soutiennent,
à tort ou à raison,
c'est pas le sujet,
l'aventure américano-britannique
en Irak...
Il y avait aussi l'Espagne
et d'autres, quand même.
Il voit dans l'Amérique
un combattant de la liberté
et de la démocratie qui va faire
la même chose en Irak.
Ce malentendu fondamental,
Jacques Chirac n'est pas le seul
à l'avoir en tête.
Je crois qu'Emmanuel Macron
a voulu effacer cette idée,
en nous avertissant aussi
quand même
que d'autres fractures
pourraient intervenir
et que ce n'est pas
du jour au lendemain que l'Europe,
de Lisbonne jusqu'à Vilnius,
ou jusqu'à Narva, à la frontière
entre l'Estonie et la Russie,
sera totalement unifiée.
La richesse de l'Europe,
c'est des histoires différentes,
de penser différemment parfois.
-Merci.
Oui, M. Fleischmann ?
-Il y a une avancée
dans la pensée "ouest-européenne"
par rapport à l'Europe centrale
dans son ensemble
et dans les pays démocratiques
nés après 1989.
Je pense que c'est
une avancée énorme
et absolument cruciale,
d'une importance énorme.
Cela montre aussi
une chose :
c'est une certaine émergence
dans le cadre de l'Europe,
de l'Europe centrale,
en tant qu'un lieu
de l'européanité
et des valeurs européennes.
On s'en aperçoit enfin.
-Oui. Alors...
Oui, M. l'ambassadeur
de Pologne ?
-Si je peux encore
ajouter une chose :
Je pense
que notre discussion
tourne autour de la Russie,
du communisme...
-Elle tourne plutôt autour
de l'Europe centrale et orientale.
-Pourquoi on a beaucoup
de difficultés
pour donner certaines définitions ?
Je pense qu'une des raisons
est qu'on n'a jamais eu
le vrai procès de Nuremberg
du communisme. Donc,
aujourd'hui,
c'est très difficile...
En début de programme,
vous avez dit :
"Il y a une petite différence
entre Lénine et Staline."
Si on se pose la question
de la vraie différence entre Staline
et Lénine, c'est le nombre de morts.
Et personne
ne sait, peut-être,
que Lénine a tué plus de personnes
que Staline.
Donc, nous vivons
dans un monde complètement...
-M. l'ambassadeur,
je voudrais poser la question,
celle qui fâche,
mais vous êtes
d'éminents représentants
de l'Europe centrale
et orientale,
et je voudrais demander :
ce qu'on reproche
à la Russie poutinienne
comme à la Russie...
tsariste,
comme à l'époque stalinienne
des bolcheviks,
c'est de mépriser
le proche étranger,
de mépriser les minorités.
Alors, je voudrais
vous poser cette question,
car vous êtes
des représentants éminents.
A l'instar d'autres minorités,
les juifs ont
constitué une communauté historique,
aujourd'hui disparue.
Si on prend des villes
comme Vilnius,
comme Sarajevo,
comme Odessa,
elles étaient
- ne parlons pas de la Pologne -,
elles étaient habitées,
pour certaines d'entre elles,
par une population juive
pour plus d'un tiers.
Or, aujourd'hui,
ces villes sont "Juden Raus",
c'est-à-dire sans juifs.
Est-ce que vous, aujourd'hui,
vous pouvez
vous engager à dire
que vous êtes prêts
à protéger les minorités
et que plus jamais
les minorités
ne seront brimées
dans cette Europe centrale
et orientale,
toutes les minorités ?
-Vous savez, je pense
que la protection des minorités
est absolument...
Comment dirais-je ?
La protection des minorités
est protégée
par les constitutions polonaise...
-Je dis
"toutes les minorités".
-On parle
de toutes les minorités.
Elles sont protégées.
Peu importe la religion, peu importe
la préférence, leur race...
-Le genre, la race, etc.
-La Pologne a une tradition
d'abord de républicanisme
très ancien,
qui date, en fait,
du 15e siècle.
Avec toutes les évolutions
de la démocratie en Pologne,
qui était réservée, bien sûr,
pour une couche sociale
relativement petite,
jusqu'au 18e siècle,
mais, en fait, on a créé,
avec les Lituaniens,
notamment à la fin du 18e siècle,
notre 1re constitution européenne,
dans laquelle on essayait
de garantir, à l'époque
- il faut penser historiquement -,
on essayait de protéger,
justement,
les nations, les individus,
la religion, etc.
Le royaume de Pologne,
c'était
le pays, à l'époque,
le plus tolérant,
car il y avait
toutes les religions
qui pouvaient s'intégrer
avec la population.
Vous savez...
-Oui, mais aujourd'hui,
il y a de nouvelles religions,
sociétales,
si vous voulez, aussi.
Ca fait partie de la modernité.
-Tout à fait.
Je pense que tous les pays
ont différentes vitesses.
-Bien sûr.
-Et je pense qu'il faut adapter
la vitesse avec la conscience
de la population.
Donc...
Bon, pour l'instant,
vous savez,
je vois pas de problème majeur
en ce qui concerne la Pologne,
tout ce qui concerne le respect
des droits des minorités...
-Pas de problème.
Pour vous,
M. Aleksiejunas ?
-C'est le point d'étudier un peu
les termes qu'on utilise,
car, pour nous, les juifs,
c'est pas une minorité, mais
une grande partie la population,
avant la 2e Guerre mondiale,
du patrimoine, de l'histoire,
car les juifs sont venus chez nous
au Moyen Age.
Ils ont bien vécu
avec nous.
Vilnius,
vous l'avez mentionné,
c'est une ville
très multiculturelle.
C'était trois religions
qui ont cohabité ensemble :
catholiques, protestants
et les juifs,
sans aucune tension,
sans aucune guerre de religion
qui existait
dans les autres régions.
Chez nous, c'était
cette tradition d'ouverture,
pour accueillir les gens
d'autres religions,
d'autres nationalités,
pour vivre sans aucune tension.
Bien sûr,
c'était la Shoah,
le nazisme,
qui ont détruit
cette harmonie
qui existait chez nous.
Bien sûr,
c'est 90 % des juifs disparus.
Mais maintenant,
il n'y a plus de question
sur cette partie de notre histoire,
de notre population,
qui est très importante, pour nous.
C'est notre propre histoire.
C'était pas juste,
comme vous avez dit, une minorité.
C'était les Lituaniens
d'origine juive,
de religion juive,
comme de religion,
aussi, provoslave. Mais c'était
un autre pays, le grand-duché
de Lituanie, c'était
la république des Deux Nations.
C'était toujours une grande partie
de notre population,
aucune minorité.
-Oui, M. Fleischmann ?
-Tout simplement, à Prague,
ça fait des siècles
qu'il n'y a pas de ghetto.
C'est la première ville qui a fait
disparaître la notion de ghetto.
Donc, on peut pas parler
de minorité juive
à Prague
ou en République tchèque,
parce qu'ils faisaient partie
intégrante de la population.
Et puis, bon, Prague,
la Bohême, en tant que telle,
est un croisement,
un croisement de cultures,
et, évidemment,
la culture juive jouait
un rôle énorme.
Prague, Vienne... Prague,
ville de Kafka.
Nous avons...
tout cet espace-là qui est ancré
dans la population tchèque,
dans la population
centro-européenne,
et ça a de l'influence.
Les seuls qui ont
relevé le défi
de l'assassinat des juifs,
c'étaient Hitler et Staline,
et Staline a vraiment tué
toute une part de la population
dans les procès
des années 1950
et, en fin de compte,
a mis au ban
toute la judaïté
de l'Europe centrale
et orientale.
Il faut s'en rendre compte.
Ce sont des besoins politiques,
pour menacer ces pays,
qui ne sont pas
des pays orientaux,
ce sont des pays occidentaux.
-Oui,
Bruno Tertrais,
cette question des minorités,
pour vous, elle n'est
plus d'actualité, dans ces pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale ?
-Je n'ai pas connaissance
de problèmes majeurs
qui puissent se poser,
dans ces pays spécifiquement,
au regard d'autres problèmes
de minorités
qu'il peut y avoir
dans d'autres pays d'Europe.
Sur la question des juifs
dans la région,
il me semble quand même
que la difficulté
d'avoir... d'être passé
de Hitler à Staline,
justement,
c'est qu'il me semble que,
dans certains de ces pays,
le temps de comprendre qu'il y avait
une spécificité de la Shoah,
que c'était quelque chose qui,
dans les têtes,
devait être bien compris,
à la fin des années 1980,
ça n'a pas forcément,
toujours et partout,
été bien compris.
J'allais dire que le retour
sur nos histoires,
nos histoires nationales
et communes,
a peut-être,
en raison des circonstances,
a peut-être été
plus rapide
dans certains pays
que dans d'autres.
C'est une chose de reconnaître
ce qui s'est passé, de commémorer,
là où ça peut être commémoré,
c'est autre chose de comprendre
à quel point ça a été
un acte fondateur, malheureusement,
dans la culture européenne moderne.
D'ailleurs,
on peut parler de l'Ukraine,
justement. Même en Ukraine,
que nous apprécions
et admirons,
aujourd'hui,
qui est européenne,
ce qui s'est passé en Ukraine
n'a pas, tout de suite
après 1991, été reconnu
comme un crime majeur
envers les juifs.
Ca a mis du temps.
C'est la réponse longue.
La courte :
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire
que, dans vos pays,
il y a des problèmes de minorités
très différents de ceux des autres.
Sur la question des juifs,
votre héritage historique
a fait
que certaines choses,
dans certains de ces pays,
ont mis plus de temps
à être comprises
par les opinions
et les populations
que dans d'autres pays.
-Oui ?
-J'aimerais
tout simplement ajouter
que cette question des minorités
est importante
dans...
La Tchécoslovaquie
a été détruite,
à Munich,
à cause
de la minorité allemande de Bohême.
Cette minorité s'était mise
du côté de Hitler,
même s'ils avaient des représentants
au Parlement
et étaient vraiment défendus
de par leurs propres députés,
etc., etc.
Mais cette utilisation
par le régime de Poutine
de minorités opposant des minorités,
face l'une à l'autre,
c'est vraiment...
On a l'impression de revenir
vraiment au siècle dernier
et se retrouver au début
de quelque chose qu'on pensait
être banni de notre histoire.
-Merci.
Un mot, monsieur l'ambassadeur
de Pologne.
-Il y a une phrase
à propos de narration
qui n'existe pas.
Cette narration n'existait pas
entre 1945 jusque 1989,
parce que cette narration libre
et naturelle ne pouvait pas exister,
parce que nos pays étaient
complètement dominés par les Russes
et par les Soviétiques.
Donc la narration
était d'une certaine façon
imposée par les occupants.
Vous avez dit
et vous avez tout à fait raison,
qu'il y a une certaine... on est
un tout petit peu en retard
dans certaines narrations.
La raison pour laquelle
nous sommes en retard est que,
pendant quelques années,
cette narration
tout simplement n'existait pas.
-Vous le savez mieux que moi, mais,
au milieu des années 1980,
par exemple,
l'image des juifs en Pologne
est une image négative encore.
C'était quelque chose qui était,
me semble-t-il,
assez bien attesté.
Il y avait parfois,
je ne voudrais pas
stigmatiser un pays,
ça existe dans d'autres pays,
un antisémitisme sans les juifs.
Ce sont
des phénomènes
et, là encore, je cherche pas
à jeter l'opprobre
sur un pays ou un autre,
mais c'est vrai que la gestion
de cette mémoire collective,
et vous n'y êtes pour rien,
a été beaucoup plus compliquée
et plus longue
que pour d'autres pays,
dans lesquels
ça a été douloureux aussi.
On parlait de Jacques Chirac.
Il faut rappeler, saluer le fait
qu'il ait... saluer
le fait qu'il ait en 1995
dit : "Vichy, c'était la France."
Et on a quand même nous-mêmes
attendu 50 ans pour reconnaître
certaines de nos responsabilités
historiques comme Français.
Donc là, j'allais dire,
nous avons tous
notre part de responsabilité,
mais chaque pays a eu une histoire
différente sur cette question.
-Merci.
On aborde les questions politiques.
Vous avez vu la citation
de Charles Michel,
président du Conseil européen,
"Bienvenue chez vous.
L'Union européenne, c'est l'Ukraine.
"L'Ukraine,
c'est l'Union européenne."
Alors, la guerre en Ukraine
a renforcé considérablement
le sentiment européen.
J'imagine que vous êtes
tous favorables,
mais il faut nous dire
quand et comment, à un élargissement
de l'Union européenne à l'Ukraine
et aux autres Etats de la région.
Qui veut commencer ?
Monsieur Aleksiejunas.
-Pour nous, c'était très clair.
Avant la guerre, nous avons
poussé déjà beaucoup cette idée
que l'Ukraine doit être intégrée
dans l'Union européenne avec l'OTAN.
C'était toujours très clair
que c'est pas possible
d'avoir la zone grise.
Quand on a le régime de Poutine,
cette zone grise encourage
de faire de la guerre,
de la pression
militaire, etc. Parce que
c'est peut-être la méthode
et aussi la mentalité
de ce régime en Russie.
Mais pour nous,
c'était un peu difficile
de persuader à l'époque,
mais maintenant,
avec la guerre, cette perspective
est très claire, perspective
avec l'Union européenne,
mais aussi pour nous,
c'est très important qu'on prépare
pour le sommet de l'OTAN
pour avoir des perspectives
pour l'Ukraine à l'OTAN.
Parce que,
pour nous, c'est difficile
d'imaginer comment avoir
la nouvelle architecture de sécurité
en Europe sans l'Ukraine avec nous,
sans avoir l'intégration
de l'Ukraine.
Et ça sera un message
très important pour Poutine,
que c'est fini, il n'a
aucune possibilité d'avoir l'Ukraine
comme une zone grise, comme
une zone d'influence de la Russie.
Et ça sera
quelque chose de très important
pour la société russe comme message
que c'est fini
avec cette idée d'impérialisme.
-Oui. Monsieur l'ambassadeur
de Pologne.
-Je pense que, tout simplement,
il faut qu'on soit conformes
aux grands penseurs,
aux grands créateurs de l'Europe.
Les pères fondateurs restent
au niveau de l'esprit
toujours très ouverts.
C'est grâce à leurs idées aussi
que la Pologne, la Lituanie,
la République tchèque,
font partie de l'Europe actuelle.
On peut pas fermer de porte,
ça, c'est la première chose,
pour différentes raisons.
-On peut les ouvrir grand
sans un dossier...
-Il faut ouvrir la porte
de façon raisonnable.
Je pense que l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui nous montre
que c'est une nation, c'est un pays,
capable de défendre
les valeurs européennes
et capable de se battre, capable
de sacrifier le sang
de ses meilleurs fils et filles,
qui se battent, qui perdent
leur vie justement pour les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres. L'Europe
a besoin de renforcements.
On a besoin de renforcements
à différents niveaux.
Au niveau économique,
au niveau démographique, etc.
L'Ukraine aujourd'hui peut
nous apporter beaucoup des actifs
que nous ne retrouvons pas
même aujourd'hui en Europe
et qui sont extrêmement précieux,
et qui vont nous permettre
de redéfinir d'une certaine façon
la nouvelle Europe, d'avoir cet élan
absolument important
pour la future croissance.
Donc la Pologne,
comme vous le savez, supporte
depuis le début l'accès de l'Ukraine
à la Communauté européenne
aussi à l'OTAN.
Bien sûr, il faut bien déterminer
le calendrier et la méthode,
mais je pense
qu'on ne peut pas permettre que
la Russie tout simplement décide
qui peut être membre
de la Communauté européenne
ou qui peut être membre de l'OTAN.
C'est inimaginable.
Aujourd'hui, pour nous, c'est
évident qu'ils doivent rejoindre
notre communauté, parce qu'ils sont
européens de premier rang
actuellement.
-Monsieur Fleischmann.
-Il faut aller
plus vite qu'on ne va
dans l'intégration des pays
qui ne sont pas encore membres
de l'Union européenne.
Il faut accélérer. On sait que ça
ne se fait pas du jour au lendemain,
mais des pays attendent
des dizaines d'années
avant de pouvoir y accéder,
alors qu'ils sont prêts.
Donc il faut accélérer. Ca veut dire
il faut quand même un peu
réformer ce système d'adhésion.
Il faut se mettre d'accord
là-dessus, comment
et dans quel espace-temps.
On a quand même aussi un autre pan.
Le président Macron
a lancé l'idée de la communauté
politique européenne,
qui a été vue un tout petit peu,
on savait pas très bien
ce que ça veut dire,
et en même temps, maintenant,
on a eu Prague, on a eu
en Moldavie le deuxième,
le troisième sera,
si je me trompe pas, à Madrid,
et après à Londres.
Donc il y a une idée
européenne d'ensemble
qui se construit
et qui, de fait, élargit l'Europe,
élargit l'Union européenne.
C'est un signal fort par rapport
à Poutine : regardez,
nous sommes 44, faites attention,
ne vous attaquez pas à nous.
Ce qui est important quand même,
c'est qu'il faut aller vite
aussi pour une raison,
c'est que la désinformation
et la puissance russe,
voire chinoise,
à travers les pays européens
est énorme et bien sûr,
tout échec de communication
de la part de l'Europe
vers ces populations, qui veulent
adhérer à l'Union européenne,
est dangereux,
parce que, tout simplement,
le vide est remplacé
par la Russie et par la Chine.
-Bruno Tertrais,
sur cet élargissement.
-Il faut s'arrêter 2 minutes
sur cette déclaration
de Charles Michel. Qui aurait dit
il y a un an et demi seulement
que ce qui est présenté
et qui nous semble à nous, autour
de ce plateau, comme une évidence
serait prononcé par une des plus
hautes autorités européennes ?
Qui l'aurait dit ?
Il faut prendre la mesure
du chemin intellectuel
et politique parcouru.
A quelque chose malheur est bon.
Le malheur, la tragédie de la guerre
en Ukraine nous a fait aussi
prendre conscience
de la réalité
fondamentalement européenne
de ce pays qui nous était présenté
quand nous étions
à l'école, au lycée ou pendant nos
études, c'était, je cite, le grenier
à blé de la Russie. C'était ça,
l'Ukraine, pour nous.
La plupart d'entre nous
ne connaissions pas l'Ukraine.
J'ai eu la chance d'y aller,
mais les Européens de la partie
occidentale ne la connaissaient pas.
Le fait de dire,
bienvenue, l'UE, c'est l'Ukraine,
l'Ukraine, c'est l'UE,
c'est phénoménal. Sur le plan
historique, c'est considérable.
Après, la question, que vous avez
commencé à soulever, c'est :
est-ce que l'Ukraine doit
prendre le chemin normal
de l'adhésion normale
et ça va prendre du temps
ou est-ce qu'il faut,
parce que les circonstances
sont historiques,
changer le processus
d'adhésion ? Je serais
favorable à un entre-deux. Changer
le processus d'adhésion
pour éviter une dérive,
pour rassurer aussi rapidement
que possible l'Ukraine, oui,
mais pas au prix
de casser le système européen qui a
tout de même certaines fragilités.
Donc réformer le système d'adhésion
pour que ça aille plus vite,
certainement.
Accepter, même si l'Ukraine
est encore en guerre,
on peut imaginer
que l'Ukraine rentre
dans l'Union européenne.
En principe, ça ne se fait pas,
mais on a bien
accepté Chypre, donc pourquoi pas ?
Ma position est un peu
entre les deux,
mais vraiment mesurons les mots
de Charles Michel,
parce que l'Ukraine
européenne, c'est
une évidence aujourd'hui pour nous,
mais pour la France et les Européens
dans la partie occidentale,
c'était absolument pas évident
il y a 2 ans.
-De l'Union européenne à l'OTAN,
il n'y a qu'un pas.
Or, monsieur l'ambassadeur
de Lituanie,
en juillet prochain,
il y a le sommet de l'OTAN
à Vilnius. Vos pays,
la Pologne, la République tchèque,
mais les pays qui constituent
cette Europe centrale,
vont-ils pousser
à une adhésion très rapide
aussi de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN ?
Etes-vous favorable ?
-Oui, nous sommes favorables
et c'est la position très claire,
publique, de notre président,
il a visité Paris
il y a deux semaines,
c'était la position
dite publiquement.
Pour nous,
c'est très important d'avoir,
peut-être pas
une adhésion immédiatement,
mais d'avoir cette perspective,
de donner cette perspective
de l'Ukraine avec nous, qu'il y a
cette possibilité d'intégration
de l'Ukraine
à l'OTAN à l'avenir, quand
les conditions seront présentes.
Personne parle pour vraiment
avoir l'Ukraine demain,
mais pour avoir cette perspective,
comme pour l'Union européenne,
pour avoir la perspective, pour
commencer le processus, pour avoir
la possibilité,
pour des discussions avec Bruxelles,
avec l'OTAN. Je me souviens très
bien de ce conseil avec la Russie,
de l'OTAN avec la Russie.
Donc il faut vraiment créer
la structure aussi, comment on peut
intégrer l'Ukraine
sans avoir l'adhésion
aujourd'hui. Donc il y a beaucoup
de possibilités, mais bien sûr,
c'est le message politique le plus
important pour donner à l'Ukraine
cet espoir, cette perspective
et ça, ça sera aussi
un message pour Poutine,
pour la Russie aussi.
-Monsieur Rosciszewski,
il y a une question
qu'on se pose en France,
concernant
la collaboration,
la coopération entre les forces
de défense et de sécurité
européennes et l'OTAN.
Comment vous voyez ça,
vous ? Est-ce qu'à terme,
il va falloir qu'il y ait une OTAN
élargie ?
Est-ce qu'à terme, il faudra
qu'il y ait une défense
européenne compacte ?
Comment vous voyez ça ?
-Nous sommes absolument sur la même
longueur d'onde avec les Lituaniens.
Nous sommes tout à fait
pour que l'Ukraine rentre
le plus vite possible à l'OTAN.
Je pense que l'Ukraine a déjà fait
des choses
absolument remarquables pour l'OTAN.
Regardez bien les effets
sur tout ce qui concerne
la mer baltique, par exemple.
L'accès de la Finlande
et le futur accès
de la Suède à l'OTAN,
c'est un renforcement
de notre sécurité, de tous nos pays,
de toutes nos nations.
C'est grâce à l'Ukraine.
Donc grâce à l'Ukraine,
il y avait
le renforcement de l'OTAN.
Donc aujourd'hui,
nous pouvons parler, nous pouvons
sentir beaucoup, beaucoup mieux
qu'il y a 2, 3 ou 4 ans.
Bon. Donc, pour nous,
c'est absolument évident
que l'Ukraine doit rentrer à l'OTAN.
Ensuite, que ce processus se passe
le plus vite possible.
Aujourd'hui, l'Ukraine, vu
l'armement qui a été livré chez eux,
constitue une des plus grandes
armées de terre européennes.
Et je pense que c'est une nation
qui est capable de se battre,
souhaite se battre
et donne un très bon exemple
à d'autres nations européennes
de comment il faut défendre.
-Est-ce que vos pays
aujourd'hui sont prêts à s'engager,
à soutenir l'Ukraine
dans une guerre très longue
pour libérer complètement
ses territoires,
quitte à s'engager
dans la guerre ?
-Aujourd'hui, la Pologne d'abord,
comme tous nos pays,
nous sommes membres de l'OTAN.
Donc nous prenons
tous les engagements
comme membres de l'OTAN.
Ce ne sont pas
des engagements individuels.
Donc la France, la Lituanie,
la République tchèque, la Pologne,
on prend tous les mêmes engagements.
Parce que nous sommes alliés
et je pense que nous devons
faire absolument tout
pour que l'Ukraine
devienne notre alliée.
La question fondamentale est
que l'Ukraine se trouve en guerre
et bien évidemment,
les pays de l'OTAN ne souhaitent pas
rentrer en guerre actuellement.
Donc il faut trouver une formule
qui permettra d'aider l'Ukraine
et de toute notre force,
sans faire engagement direct
en guerre. C'est difficile.
C'est difficile. Mais
c'est indispensable de l'autre côté.
Mais je pense que nous avons besoin
tous, comme Alliance atlantique,
justement d'avoir un allié comme
l'Ukraine, le plus vite possible.
-Oui, c'est votre avis,
monsieur Fleischmann ?
-Nous constatons tous
que la présence de l'OTAN
comme couverture de défense
même de l'Europe
s'est montrée efficace et existante.
Même le président Macron a reconnu
une renaissance de l'OTAN
dans son discours de Bratislava.
-On soigne les AVC.
-Mais, en même temps, il est évident
que l'Europe en tant que telle,
l'Union européenne
en tant que telle,
a montré aussi sa capacité
de se mettre d'accord ensemble
et d'aider l'Ukraine
dans sa défense de son territoire.
Donc l'OTAN, bien sûr,
l'Union européenne et la défense
de l'Union européenne, aussi.
Je pense que c'est important
que cette autonomie européenne,
ce sens
de l'autonomie européenne existe
et que ça ne disparaisse pas
quelque part.
Donc, comme on dit,
se regarder les yeux dans les yeux.
Cela dit, vous dites,
attaquer la Russie, le problème,
personne ne veut
attaquer la Russie.
Nous voulons défendre notre Europe
et nos pays européens
comme l'est l'Ukraine,
qu'elle soit dans l'OTAN
ou qu'elle soit
dans l'Union européenne.
Maintenant, s'attaquer à la Russie,
on n'a pas envie.
Mais il faudrait aussi
avoir un interlocuteur
et on n'a pas d'interlocuteur.
Qui est en face de nous ? Poutine,
mais est-ce qu'il nous parle ? Non.
Il nous attaque, il nous parle pas,
c'est autre chose.
Nous n'avons pas
avec qui discuter de l'arrêt
et de la fin de ce conflit
et de constituer vraiment
une Union européenne
et bien sûr l'OTAN.
-Bruno Tertrais,
là-dessus.
-Premièrement,
l'Ukraine entrera
dans l'OTAN un jour.
On lui dit depuis 2008
que, si elle veut entrer,
elle aura le droit d'être candidate.
Deuxième point,
le "un jour" ne peut pas être
maintenant que le pays
est en guerre,
parce que c'est un pays
qu'on s'engagerait
à défendre,
alors qu'il est en guerre.
Quand vous êtes formellement
dans l'OTAN,
vous devez défendre
votre territoire.
Donc ça sera pas tout de suite.
Quand exactement ? On ne sait pas.
Dans l'intervalle, il faut s'engager
résolument pour lui dire :
tant que vous n'aurez pas récupéré
votre territoire, on vous
soutiendra. Après la guerre,
elle sera la 1re ligne de défense
de l'Europe, une des plus grandes
armées de terre d'Europe,
l'armée la plus aguerrie d'Europe,
ce sera notre 1re ligne de défense
contre la Russie. Dernier point,
votre titre, "L'Europe
qui veut en finir avec Poutine".
Quelle Russie aurons-nous après ?
Nous ne le savons pas.
Je fais partie de ceux qui estiment
que des relations normales
avec la Russie
ne seront pas possibles
tant que Poutine sera là.
C'est terminé.
C'est une rupture historique,
ça n'est pas possible et c'est vrai
pour toute l'Europe. En revanche,
est-ce que nous, nous voulons
en finir avec Poutine
de manière active ?
Est-ce que nous allons soutenir
après la défaite russe
un changement de régime en Russie ?
Là, il n'y aurait pas
de consensus européen pour le faire.
La vraie question, ça sera :
est-ce que nous devons,
Européens et Occidentaux,
aider les mouvements
qui pourraient éventuellement
naître en Russie d'opposition
à Poutine, comme nous avons aidé,
comme nous vous avons aidés,
à l'époque du Rideau de Fer,
où il y avait
une aide occidentale,
notamment américaine,
aux mouvements de libération ou
de défense des droits de l'homme ?
Ce sera la question suivante.
Et au vu de votre titre,
il faut clarifier un malentendu.
On a Poutine,
mais je connais peu d'Européens
prêts à aller se battre
pour changer le régime russe.
-On va terminer sur cette question
et avoir votre avis à chacun.
Comment vous voyez la collaboration,
imaginons
que cette guerre se termine,
il faudra bien qu'elle se termine.
Comment vous imaginez
la collaboration
entre cette nouvelle Europe
en train de se constituer
et la Russie ?
Est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
mettre K.-O. en quelque sorte
l'impérialisme russe ?
Ou est-ce qu'il faut
vivre... on aura
une espèce de nouvelle
guerre froide entre les pays
démocratiques et libéraux
et des pays qui sont nationalistes
et expansionnistes ?
Que chacun donne son avis
sur un futur optimiste,
si on peut dire.
-Si je peux
me permettre, je pense
que l'on revient justement
à cette aide de l'Europe centrale
et orientale dans les années 80
et dans les années 90.
Je pense qu'on vit aujourd'hui
dans une certaine peur justement
de l'après-Poutine.
Poutine, c'est terminé.
Poutine, c'est terminé,
il a perdu toute crédibilité,
il est impossible de le croire,
d'avoir confiance en ce qu'il signe.
Donc, Poutine, je pense,
c'est terminé.
-Celui qui lui succédera
peut être pire.
-Il peut.
Qu'est-ce que vous en savez ?
Peut-être.
Mais cela dit, je pense qu'on a
des peurs totalement inutiles
de se poser la question
de l'après-Poutine.
Ca va être...
-Mais de l'après-Russie
poutinienne,
plutôt que d'après Poutine.
-La Russie sera toujours la Russie.
La Russie n'oubliera pas de sitôt
ses idéaux impérialistes,
expansionnistes. La Russie
n'oubliera pas de sitôt
ce qu'il faut faire, ne pas oublier,
ne pas se faire kidnapper l'Occident
et ne pas se faire
kidnapper ses populations
qui sont toujours
liées à la Russie
et qui veulent aussi
leur indépendance.
Il ne faut pas oublier
tous ces dissidents russes
qui existent
et qui ne sont pas tous partis.
Il faut les aider
pour continuer cette pensée
des valeurs européennes
sans les imposer,
mais tout simplement
être un exemple.
-Monsieur
Jan Emeryk Rosciszewski, êtes-vous
en accord avec ça ?
Est-ce qu'il faut désimpérialiser
la Russie
après une éventuelle défaite
de la Russie en Ukraine ?
-A propos de ce que vous avez dit en
ce qui concerne l'aide occidentale
à tous nos pays
à l'époque communiste,
c'est un très bon exemple,
mais pas tout à fait comparable.
Parce que nos sociétés étaient
complètement différentes.
-Tout à fait.
-En comparaison
avec la société russe actuelle.
Moi, je vois pas beaucoup de points
de comparaison à vrai dire.
J'imagine très bien l'Europe...
l'Europe avec l'Ukraine.
C'était votre première,
première question.
Je vois l'intégration européenne
parfaitement bien
avec l'Ukraine, avec d'autres pays,
les Balkans occidentaux, etc.
Par contre, franchement,
je sais ce que ça veut dire
la Russie actuellement.
Je vois pas, ce que disait
monsieur l'ambassadeur Fleischmann,
avec qui vraiment
on peut parler là-bas. D'abord,
il n'y a pas
une vraie opposition. Il faut
pas oublier... Un tout petit peu de
statistiques, c'est très important.
Depuis que Poutine est le président
d'Etat, chaque année, il y a
500 000 personnes qui émigrent
de la Russie. La dernière année,
2,5 millions de personnes
ont quitté la Russie.
Si on compte 23 ans
ou 24 ans de la présidence
de Poutine, on arrive
au chiffre de presque 15 millions
de jeunes Russes,
en dessous de la quarantaine,
qui ont quitté le pays.
Ca veut dire qu'aujourd'hui,
au niveau
de la pyramide démographique,
on a un trou gigantesque
des personnes les plus jeunes
et les mieux éduquées.
Tout ce qui reste,
bon, je veux pas appeler par...
-Il reste, pardon,
que l'Ukraine avant la guerre
n'était pas
dans une situation démographique
très favorable non plus.
-Quand même.
-Il nous reste peu de temps.
Je pense que vous avez un argument
très fort et c'est vrai d'ailleurs,
qui est dénoncé
depuis plusieurs semaines
par Madame Carrère d'Encausse,
à savoir que la Russie a perdu
une bonne partie de ses élites
et qu'elle sera affaiblie
durablement.
Monsieur Aleksiejunas,
vous, vous voyez comment
la relation de l'Europe
qui se constitue aujourd'hui
avec une Russie dépoutinisée
ou en tout cas quelle Russie ?
Comment vous voyez l'avenir ?
Parce que
la Lituanie, je crois
que c'est le dernier checkpoint
Charlie. Vous êtes tout près,
vulnérables à la Russie.
-Oui. Je pense que notre expérience,
et je suis d'accord
avec mon collègue tchèque
qu'il faut éviter cette peur
de la Russie après la guerre.
Parce que c'était la même chose
au début de notre indépendance.
C'était la même peur de la chute
de l'Union soviétique.
Il faut éviter cette peur.
C'est pas imaginer
tous les scénarios,
pour moi, c'est toujours
ce slogan russe très connu
que c'est pas possible
de comprendre la Russie.
Le scénario peut
devenir différent. Un petit exemple.
Qui aurait pu imaginer que
Svetlana Tsikhanovskaïa deviendrait
une opposante clé en Biélorussie ?
Il y a, je sais pas, un an
avant les élections en Biélorussie.
Ca donne cette compréhension que
c'est un peu difficile d'imaginer
maintenant un leader,
qui sera provocateur
de changements en Russie.
Donc il faut vraiment éviter
cette peur.
-N'oublions pas ce qui s'est passé
en Allemagne en 1945.
Il y avait tout le processus
de dénazification de l'Allemagne.
On peut le juger, ça s'est bien
passé ou mal, mais en fait...
-La différence, c'est que nous
ne marcherons pas jusqu'à Moscou.
-Le problème
de la dépoutinisation
ou décommunisation
ou de la dérussification
de la Russie même, aujourd'hui,
c'est difficilement imaginable.
-Merci.
Ecoutez...
Voilà. Ecoutez, on a terminé,
on fera d'autres émissions
sur le sujet. Laissez-moi
suggérer une bibliographie
sur ce sujet. "La reconstruction
"des nations",
de Timothy Snyder.
Je voudrais
également signaler
de Nicolas Baverez :
Alors, on a parlé amplement
de Milan Kundera.
Voilà un opuscule
très important :
Chez Gallimard.
Je voudrais également
évidemment
souligner l'oeuvre
d'Adam Mickiewicz, "Pan Tadeusz",
c'est publié
chez Noir et Blanc.
Un très grand ouvrage.
C'est un poème épique
sur ce grand-duché
de Lituanie. Et donc
il y a quelque chose,
je crois qu'il faut faire
référence à cette histoire
culturelle pour avancer.
Et de Bruno Tertrais,
"La guerre".
-C'est pas un poème.
-C'est pas un poème, mais
c'est un ouvrage
qui nous permet
aussi de mieux appréhender
les enjeux martiaux aujourd'hui,
en Ukraine.
Voilà, je voudrais
vous remercier,
messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission. Je voudrais
remercier l'équipe de LCP.
Et avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous soumettre
cette citation : "On m'a
souvent posé la question
"pourquoi suis-je resté
"et n'ai-je pas fui ?
Parce que
"si j'avais fui,
tout le monde aurait fui."
C'est de qui ?
C'est le héros du jour,
Volodymyr Zelensky.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA